le projet Paris saclé est d'ors et déjà
structuré autour de nombreuses
institutions d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche et le nouveau centre de
safran vient renforcer la composante
entrepreneuriale et industrielle de ce
plateau côté de sociétés comme d'assau
système Air Liquide à laquelle lin ou
encore talè maisi au côté de pépinière
de start-up qu'il sera tout à fait
important de développer encore
davantage on a cherché à avoir un
équilibre on veut des gens tous les
horizons parce qu'on pense que au-delà
de l'excellence scientifique le fait
d'avoir la diversité de culture est
importante donc on chercha à avoir un
équilibre entre des gens qui viennent de
SAFR et puis des gens qui viennent de la
recherche ou d'autres industries et qui
V nous apporter un regard extérieur et
des connaissances plus connectées avec
la recherche re scientifique aujourd'hui
on a un bon équilibre on a un peu plus
de 60 % de gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur qui viennent d'autres
industries mais beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines universitair ou qui sortent de
thèse dans les meilleurs labos on
voulait avoir des gens de haut niveau
donc on voulait avoir beaucoup de gens
au niveau doctorat qui est approfondi
leurs connaissances on a à peu près 2
tiers on a des doctorants aussi on a une
vingtaine et on essera de monter jusqu'à
une quarantaine on a une vingaine de
pourcent de gens qui sont soit étrangers
soit qui ont la nationalité donc on a un
creusé mais ce qui qui est important
pour nous c'est la diversité et de
l'excellence scientifique on a des
partenariats historiques et qu'on a
qu'on a développé à l'occasion de notre
implantation avec le CEA on a tout un
tas d'écoles avec qui on a des
partenariats historiques on veut
renforcer les lien avec la formation je
pense qu'on peut attirer plus
d'étudiants on peut valoriser les
formations par la recherche et en
bénéficier on est dans les meilleures
conditions pour le faire les
infrastructures peuvent être encore un
peu amélioré sur le niveau des
transports mais c'est vraiment ça qui
nous attire
on va travailler sur sur trois axes de
recherche un axe sur plutôt sur les
systèmes ce qu'on appelle système et
technologie où on va travailler sur la
compréhension de l'énergétique des
avions des avions plus électriques donc
de leur architecture l'architecture de
nos clients on a un deuxième a qui est
sur les matériaux et les composants donc
on travaille sur tous les matériaux dont
on en a besoin pour la propulsion et
l'avion plus électrique et puis on
travaille sur les composants
électroniques tout ce qui va nous
permett de disposer dans nos systèmes de
de nouvelles données d'exploiter des
nouveaux services pour nos clients enfin
le dernier axe c'est ce sont les
technologies du numérique avec la
modélisation la simulation pour
modéliser nos produits et puis un axe
sur le traitement du signal et
d'information encore pour améliorer la
performance et offrir de nouveaux
services à nos
clients